a
chen wei es una celebridad y una heroína
nacional en china dónde es conocida como
la terminator de los virus nació en la
provincia de zheijiang estudió químicas
y en contra de los consejos de amigos y
familiares rechazó las lucrativas
ofertas del sector privado y se enroló
en el ejército donde hoy ostenta el
cargo de general tiene una larga
experiencia de lucha contra los virus
ayudó a embridar la epidemia del sars en
2002 impidió las infecciones tras el
terremoto de sichuan de 2008 y lideró la
segunda fase de ensayos clínicos de la
vacuna contra el ébola en sierra leona
en jan aterrizó en la víspera del año
nuevo chino 50 días después ya tenía
lista la primera vacuna experimental
dice chen que su profundo sentido del
deber sobrevuela la extenuación y la
soledad durante el sars encadenó cien
días encerrada en el laboratorio incluso
utilizó pañales para reducir las visitas
al baño y de aquellos días es famosa la
célebre foto de su hijo pequeño besando
la pantalla de la televisión cuando
salía
a la que no había visto durante meses
[Música]
la doctora sarah gilbert es la
arquitecta de la vacuna oxford
astrazéneca contra el kobe y es además
una de las científicas más importantes
de la actualidad nacida en inglaterra en
1962 es actualmente la directora del
prestigioso instituto en gener y
profesora de la universidad de oxford
quien desde muy joven supo que quería
ser científica ha trabajado en el
desarrollo de las vacunas contra la
malaria el ébola también una universal
contra la influenza y recientemente
contra el síntoma respiratorio del medio
oriente cuyos avances le permitieron
desarrollar en tiempo récord la vacuna
contra el hobbit 19 quienes la conocen
dicen que es como la mujer maravilla
porque además es madre de trillizos
quienes actualmente estudian en la
universidad bioquímica
[Música]
cuando le preguntaron al ibi homólogo de
la casa blanca- anthony fauci sobre cuál
era el aporte de los científicos
afroamericanos en la creación de la
vacuna este respondió que la vacuna de
moderna que tiene una efectividad de
hasta el 95 por ciento fue creada porque
es media corp
una doctora afroamericana ella es
alguien que pasará a la historia como
una de las jugadoras clave en el
desarrollo de la ciencia para que acabe
la pandemia dijo fauci que es magia es
una de las científicas líder del
instituto nacional de salud y trabajo
con modernas para desarrollar esta
vacuna estudió química en la universidad
de carolina del norte donde también hizo
un doctorado en microbiología e
inmunología según fauci el rol de
corvette como una de las científicas
detrás de las vacunas debe ser un
símbolo de esperanza para la comunidad
afroamericana que duda de ponerse la
vacuna a pesar de ser una de las más
afectadas por la pandemia
[Música]